[Musique]
m'appelle pierre ducharme je suis
présentement étudiant à l'école des
métiers du meuble de montréal
[Musique]
le boulot bref c'est un entreprise
réinsertion pour les gens qui ont de la
difficulté qui sont soit dans la rue ou
qui ont simplement des difficultés ça
peut être avec la drogue ça fait des
maladies mentales a fait de toutes
sortes
j'ai quelqu'un qui consommaient beaucoup
de drogue c'est des drogues fortes tout
ça je faisais tout le temps c'est au
travail
[Musique]
quand on est arrivé ici on m'a proposé
par un blanc c'est comme un contrôle se
fait avec toi même avec eux
[Musique]
bien vite en cours d'ébénisterie bleu au
vert quand on arrive ici on est dans un
cul de sac où les choses ne vont pas
bien ça tourne à 8 mais je me devais
d'être servis au verre avoir vu jaune
stade jacques tati belles choses
félicitations on voit le processus pour
début à la fin d'un morceau de bois avec
des cordes ils trouvent un accord
un meuble qui dans le coin d'une
garderie pied fini qui est là qui brille
c'est vraiment fini
ici c'est un de plateformes d'essais
j'ai pu essayer toutes sortes de choses
j'ai pu tomber j'ai pu me relever
j'étais un modèle d'assiduité des gens
partent à exprimer mes idées je ne sais
pas non plus
dimensions prend le dessus sur moi donc
été j'avais quand même un contrôle que
je pense que c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
ont décidé les chefs d'équipé a été une
fierté pour moi content tu avais fait
c'est moi sans aucune consommation qui
en sortant de là mais je n'ai pas
consommé du tout donc ça me permet de
pouvoir aller à l'école
on est présentement à l'école des
métiers du meuble de montréal je suis
présentement en train de faire un cours
en finition de meubles d'un diplôme
d'études professionnelles
ensuite je vis beaucoup les grosses
usines comme bombardier je me verrais
bien travaillé là dedans idéalement mont
wright c'est vraiment être à mon compte
puis d'avoir mes collègues lui
il obtient ici seront pas manger les
gens n'ont plus ils sont pas magiques
t'es vraiment un effort qu'on donne de
soi qu'ils étaient les outils je les ai
manier les gens d'aller les chercher
c'est vraiment faut sortir pour se
construire il faut juste attendre ses
six mois ça passe très vite si moi mais
aussi à mon conseil c'est vraiment
prendre chacun des secondes qui à
chacune des journées pour essayer de
dire j'ai dû changer aujourd'hui je suis
arrangé quelque chose
on peut dire que en construisant les
meubles c'est abou lover mais ça m'a
permis aussi en même temps de me
reconstruire
[Musique]